good morning Hank it's Tuesday so uh
it's been a rough week rough couple
months really and I know the hard part
for you is just beginning as you start
chemo and mostly I just want you to know
that I love you and that there are a lot
of people in your corner that noted
yesterday you and I were talking on the
phone and Sarah came in after we chatted
and she said what was so funny because
apparently we were laughing a lot and
like obviously you having lymphoma is
not a hilarious turn of events but there
are funny aspects to it like it was
pretty funny when you wrote on Twitter
I'm getting chemo send me Pelican pics
and then replied a couple minutes later
I'm sorry if this is how you found out
and it was funny when someone wrote on
Tumblr not me wondering which All-Star
lyric Hank would have picked had this
happened during the vlogbrothers
All-Star era like the World's Gonna Roll
me as the obvious one but I think you
might have gone for something a little
more abstract like the ice we skate also
it was funny when with your enthusiastic
encouragement the website days since
Hank Green started a newthing.com reset
to zero with the new thing not being a
YouTube channel or a Soap Company but
chemotherapy and it was funny albeit
less intentionally when I went to our
YouTube account and it was like hey
sorry about the cancer but congrats on
all the views here's some confetti this
is a phenomenon I've witnessed a bunch
in my life as a Chaplain as a kid whose
dad had cancer twice when we were little
and also when I've had serious health
problems of my own it's awful it's
terrifying it's not always or even
usually funny but it is sometimes funny
if the laughs come from a place of love
and understanding for instance I didn't
find it particularly funny when someone
answered the question who is Hank Green
with he's some kind of YouTuber book
with cancer like I get that's trying to
be clever but just ick to work the humor
has to feel like love rather than
judgment like inclusion rather than
stigma and like celebration rather than
dismissal and that's a tough balance
sometimes well-intentioned people
including me get it wrong and it also
depends on like who's saying it and the
context like when I was hospitalized
with meningitis my best friend Chris
showed up at the ER and the first thing
he said was I thought you'd already had
all of the itises which I thought was
hilarious but if my doctor had said it I
would have been less amused so listen I
don't understand how grief and fear and
uncertainty live alongside humor but I
know they have to because life in all of
its complexity and Paradox is still life
like at Partners in Health they talk a
lot about accompaniment walking
someone's path with them so they don't
feel alone listening always and helping
when you can for PIH that's key to good
health care but I think for all of us
it's key to a good life now Hank you
specifically said you were good with
prayers so this is my prayer for you and
for all of us I pray that we may be
justified in Our Hope and un alone in
our sorrow all right there is one more
thing to talk about I know this is an
incredibly difficult time for you and
for our family and for this community
but please spare a thought for the
employees of dftba.com our merch company
and complexly our educational video
production company who now have this guy
Kirkland brand Hank Green as their
temporary CEO I mean I Now understand
concretely what I used to know only
abstractly which is that Hank Green does
a lot of things very well and now John
Green is gonna do some of those things
less well but like the world still needs
crash course and scishow and everything
else complexly makes and our colleagues
from Missoula to Sierra Leone are
counting on us to continue the awesome
coffee and socks clubs and everything
else dftba makes so I do want to say how
grateful I am to the over 100 people who
work for those companies for stepping up
and supporting each other through this
and I also want to say thank you to
everyone in this community for your
kindnesses toward us and toward each
other it has meant a lot this week I'm
so grateful to y'all for being here with
us Hank whether I see you on Friday or
not I'll see you soon